man mexican people work  work hard as hell man i got to be honest  with you never no complaining just  work hard dude i went to a funeral of a  mexican guy he climbed out of the casket  dug his own grave hole and then got back  in the casket man if i got to do  something for example i need to build a  picnic table or a  you know edible seating  structure  you know table and i got i got nine  people to help me do it if six out of  the nine people are mexican bro  on delay papa we getting it done i'm  telling you that dude i'm telling you  that we're gonna be eating lunch early  as a group look i saw a mexican guy cut  down a tree  make it into wood bars  bars of wood  and then use the wood to make a heat  that he built a damn tree with it  and s  inspiracional  papa